(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] Stroopwafel.
- I like the look of this.
- It looks like a mini waffle
so I'm sold.
- [All] Ting!
- Yes.
- Amazing.
- What is in this?
- Oh, man, this is good.
- Oh, look at that.
- [All] Oooh.
- There's something in the middle
and it's sticky and yummy.
- It's like a caramel waffle cookie.
- Delicious, it's got like a crunch
when you first bite into it,
but then it's like soft.
- I would definitely recommend this.
- [Voiceover] Haribo Trekdrop.
- Ooh, what on earth?
- Look at this kid on the front!
- He's having a blast, look, it stretches!
- [All] Ah!
- Ow.
- Aw, God, that's gross.
- Probably shouldn't eat
this, it's like rubber.
- I've never had anything
with this texture before.
I don't know what it is.
- Tastes like Jägermeister.
Bad, bad memories.
- Not a fan.
- I liked it a lot.
- I'm, I mean I like playing with it
more than I like eating it.
- [Voiceover] Boterkoek.
- It looks like old tofu.
- This is slightly orgasmic.
- It's kinda got this
interesting texture to it.
- Yeah.
- I can't put my finger on it.
- Pretty hard on the outside
and nice and soft on the inside.
- It tastes like a stick of butter.
- Yeah.
- With sugar on it.
- It is pretty oily.
I don't know if you can see that.
- It's delicious.
- It is, it's really good.
- It's so good.
- In fact, I'm gonna have
that last one.
- [Voiceover] Autodrop Cadillacs.
- Oh, this smells so good.
- Can you get drunk off of it?
- And kids eat these?
- Pink cada, vroom!
- It kinda looks like a Jetsons' cars.
- Isn't this kind of promoting
drunk driving in a way?
- They are hard as a rock.
- Yeah, I'm gonna have this
later tonight when I'm sleeping.
- This is like gummies for adults.
Like I would (beep) with these.
- [Voiceover] Van Dungen Jamaica Rumbonen.
- Jamaican rum filled chocolates.
- It looks like someone
just pooped in a box.
- Do you think it's gonna be,
rum is gonna come out
of then like a drink?
- Probably.
(surprised gagging)
- Oh, (beep).
- Oh.
- Oh, my God.
- What the (beep) happened?
I guess it was just like, poof!
- It's strong too.
- Yeah.
- This is not a joke.
- You gotta give a girl
a little warning here
before you decide to shoot
something off like that.
- Yeah.
- It's making me cry.
- Oooh.
- 2.7% alcohol.
- I can taste it.
- I wonder how many it would
take to get you full on drunk.
- You could get drunk off
of this whole package.
- I don't know, I liked it.
I thought it was great.
You get alcohol, you get chocolate,
it's just a little bit of everything.
- I'm offended by this candy to be honest.
I wish I had known.
(laughing)
Like let me know, let me know,
and then I'll make a
decision to swallow or not.
(laughing)